so as we continue to wait for and wonder
is republican congressman matt gates
going to be charged um for possibly
child sex trafficking and or other
crimes the investigation is ongoing matt
gates has retained lawyers expert in
defending against sex crimes as we
wonder about that his behavior continues
to become more and more outrageous and
over the weekend matt gates actually i
guess you could call it joking i'm not
really sure
matt gates joked about blowing up
capital metal detectors
with explosives
um this of course relates to the metal
detectors that were installed at the
capitol
at least in part because it was believed
that some republican members of congress
including lauren beaubert maybe others
madison cawthorne has talked about being
being armed being protected uh bringing
weapons onto the house floor
so we're gonna go through this piece by
piece mediaite article says while
campaigning for a republican
congressional candidate in central
florida on saturday congressman matt
gates complained about the metal
detectors in the capitol lying about why
they were installed and going so far as
to joke about blowing them up with
explosives
the former the florida congressman was
in lake county to campaign for florida
state rape rep anthony sabatini sabatini
who was running for congress in 2022 and
shares gates support for former
president donald trump gates mentioned
congresswoman lauren bobert's objection
to the metal detectors that were
installed in the capitol complex shortly
after the trump riots multiple
republican lawmakers loudly complained
about the metal detectors claiming they
were a violation of their constitutional
rights they weren't and beaubert was
among those who attempted to circumvent
the screening
by walking around the metal detectors or
refusing
to allow her bag to be searched all
right so let's take a look at the first
clip here here is matt gates talking
about blowing up the metal detectors in
the house with either tannerite or c4
explosive my friend lauren bobert from
colorado she
they put in metal detectors on the floor
of the house because it's like a five
foot nothing woman she carries a firearm
for her personal protection so oh they
got triggered by that i said man is it
is it tananite or c4 we want to put in
those metal detectors when we blow them
up and we take them
yeah
now
in all seriousness
this is the exact type of thing that
causes stochastic violence if not
stochastic terror
aside from whether it's even appropriate
absent any real world implications for a
sitting member of congress to be joking
about or maybe not joking uh talking
about blowing up the chamber in which he
works and votes and in which legislative
duties are carried out whether you can
say that's fine or it's not fine or
whatever
if you have an understanding if you
recognize and realize
the degree to which
disproportionately the types of people
that follow someone like matt gates
are folks who um
would be willing to do violence in real
life to solve political issues
you start to realize
this could actually encourage someone to
go and to try to set off a bomb at the
house now would they get into where the
metal detectors are maybe not
but that's not really a defense this is
we've talked about stochastic terror
given a large enough audience if you
hammer on and hammer on and hammer on an
idea and radicalize people against a
person or institution it starts to
become statistically likely that someone
it wouldn't be predictable exactly who
but that whoa sorry for hitting my mic
that someone is going to go out
and um actually act on that now as a
reminder we recently had more context to
this lauren bobert was recently
interviewed by a cultural critic and
arbiter of ideas dave rubin and lauren
bobert sort of smiled and laughed and
kind of took credit supposedly for the
metal detectors even being there
remember this from last week nancy
pelosi has called me the enemy within
we have metal detectors outside of the
house chambers because of me
and uh
so so it seems so they now are
ridiculing what are actions that had to
be taken
because members of congress posed a risk
in terms of the weapons they were trying
to bring in as i said last week it's not
something to be proud about
that your place of work had to put in
metal detectors because of your actions
it's not that i would be humiliated if
that were the case
also from this same very strange
appearance here matt gates says he
thinks democrats are going to see
how many republican votes are there and
then they will illegally create
democratic votes to counter that sort of
like as a one-to-one thing completely
baseless no evidence of this take a look
at matt gates's suggestion i really
think they like in fulton county georgia
i think they wait and they see how many
votes the republicans got in the other
parts of the state and then that's how
many they need to like will into
existence so that's a completely
unfalsifiable claim
um you can always look at election
results and say oh
democrats won by a thousand
democrats actually really lost by a
thousand but they checked how many
republican votes they were and then they
created two thousand democratic votes to
take a thousand vote lead completely
unfalsifiable hasn't happened no
evidence that it's happened no evidence
that democrats have attempted it
just more poisoning the well that type
of thing only works on ignorant voters
there's no evidence that that's done and
it would be completely unfalsifiable
just look you can look at any election
result and in fact they're doing it mike
pillow does it and these people do it
they say no no no no no trump really won
wisconsin by two hundred thousand
really where's the evidence well they
won't give us the evidence oh okay well
then so how would we
this is this they he really won you
can't falsify a lot of these things and
that's what makes them great fodder for
low information voters